hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash popcorn boxes and candy wrappers
hmm they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me and thank you
for considering your fellow patrons all
right everybody welcome to the Tim Dylan
show heading back from LAX just picked
up by Ben the producer because they are
no longer allowing ubers and lyft's at
LAX because they are blaming uber and
lyft for the fact that their Airport is
poorly designed and it was not designed
with the flow of traffic in mind they
didn't think that might potentially be
an issue down the road so there's just
endless bottlenecking if you've ever
been to that Airport it is insane but
you know the big news today the big news
which everybody is focused on because it
affects them personally is the
chick-fil-a sandwich shop has decided to
end its donations to groups that have
been called anti LGBT I don't know what
groups they are apparently they're
Christian groups and everybody is
reacted you know to this you see people
on Twitter like ben shapiro being like i
can't believe you did this
you you you thrived as a company by
serving everybody and now you've let
canceled culture win and of course you
have like dave rubin who's gay by the
way dave Reubens like said i will not be
eating chick-fil-a anymore
DJ Reubens gay and Dave Reubens going
he's not eating chick-fil-a anymore and
he's gonna start making chicken
sandwiches at his house he felt the need
to tweet that he's an adult he's an
adult and felt the need to tweet that he
would be making chicken at home now okay
dave rubin would go to Egypt where they
or Saudi Arabia where they were like
crucify
young gay kids and and if they stop that
policy Dave Rubin would be like this is
another instance of canceled culture
winning it's just another instance of
canceled culture with yes I'm gay
but I see no problem with the cultural
execution of gay people and anyone that
does I don't care what chick-fil-a does
it doesn't matter to me I don't know
what these charities were if some of the
charities were you know if you want to
donate to Christian organizations great
they don't you know they opposed
same-sex marriage fine it gets a little
stickier to me if they're like
advocating you know the abuse of
children like I'm trying to like the the
camp's that people send their gay kids
to to try to turn them straight I'm
trying to think of the name of that
conversion therapy so conversion therapy
so if your funding conversion therapy
I'm not really cool with it but again
it's still you know if I was on the line
at chick-fil-a and you came to me and
they're like a another fun conversion
therapy it would really depend on how
hungry I was at the moment if you came
to me on the line at Wendy's you went oh
Wendy's has declared that they are
supporting the Caliphate the Islamic
caliphate and that all infidels should
be slaughtered if I was on the Wendy's
line I was hungry I'd be like all right
but let's talk about it later let's get
to it later because boycotts don't work
in this country because do the real
religion in this country is morbid
obesity and I travel all over the car I
see what it is so stop lying that you're
not gonna eat chick-fil-a anymore you're
gonna start grilling salmon with your
fat kids you're not you're gonna do this
for a few days and then you're gonna go
back to chick-fil-a because it's hot and
it's handed to you through a window and
it's wrapped in paper which is what
American cuisine is it's something that
was deep-fried mass-produced made of
poison wrapped in paper and handed you
through a window and you could throw it
at your children
they scream in the back of the car so
let's not act like that's gonna stop
anytime soon
stop with the boycotts and to get on
your moral high horse
chick-fil-a can do what they want I
didn't yell when they donated take Greg
anti-gay groups it shouldn't so now
everyone's gonna yell when they said
well we don't we're not gonna do that
anymore who knows why they're not doing
it maybe they want to expand in the
city's more liberal markets they're a
corporation where it's not a Christian
company anymore
there's no such thing as a Christian
corporation you dummies it doesn't exist
what part of the Bible are you reading
where you live like Jesus walking around
talking about maximizing shareholder
profit this was a guy who walked around
he hung out with like prostitutes he
tried to feed the hungry yeah it's not a
Christian company anymore
well then don't eat there then grill
salmon and eat broccoli and go on walks
and try to survive it won't happen we
know it won't happen we just know for a
fact it won't happen I love they go so
the only organizations at chick-fil-a
foundation will donate to in 2020 our
covenant house International Junior
Achievement of America and local
community food banks I mean who gives a
[ __ ] really truly but can you stop
pretending that boycotts are gonna work
people say that the Gillette ad lost
Gillette eight billion dollars
Gillette's razors at $38 no one can
afford that people don't shave anymore
it's not the dumb Gillette ad you know
the ad might not have helped the ad was
stupid the toxic masculinity ad but most
people saw it online they saw it on
YouTube people don't make snap decisions
they they go and buy the razor that is
cheap and available people are a lot of
people don't have the luxury of
participating in your moral Crusades one
way or the other I know that's
unfathomable for you to believe
there's people in a situation that
teachers have to buy what's around they
can't just sit back and make choices
based on how they feel go ass if we were
pulling to LAX this advant going to be
these workers if they give a [ __ ] who
chick-fil-a donates to it's hot and it's
available and they got to go back to
work
they could have Satanist handing out
those sandwiches it doesn't matter this
country is a country of fat slobs that
are not going to start taking
responsibility for their own lives
they're not they're not that's why we
eat this [ __ ] we want to die we know
we're the problem we know we know
humanity's it is a disease we see each
other we look at everything beautiful
the oceans you know the sunsets if we go
the only thing that's really polluting
this [ __ ] planet is us so
subconsciously we want to die so we're
just that's what it is
I I just love the you know as I always
said texting somebody who was like you
know chick-fil-a there they're turning
on their core constituency their core
constituency is fat people yes there are
some southern fit of course the South
goes Christians go blah blah blah maybe
they lose a few dollars they'll make up
for it by just putting them in in
liberal City it doesn't matter they
don't care they're a corporation they
don't give a [ __ ] they just want to sell
chicken sandwiches they're only trying
to sling chicken sandwiches I'm not I'm
gonna Dave Rubin I'm gonna make them in
my home good good you and your [ __ ]
husband who's probably so embarrassed
that poor guy god only knows who David J
Reuben married somebody who's probably
stealing money from his bank account and
good for him
if I married a dude if I was as
embarrassing his Dave Rubin and I got
married to a guy I would hope and pray
that he was stealing from me every day I
hope to god Dave Reubens husband's him
dazzling money from him every [ __ ]
day some twink who's just like God no
it's your make a lot of sense Dave
you're gonna make the chicken in the
house now no you did great opening for
Jordan beater thin
you were so funny I said Dave Rubin um
you know a chef here went to Jordan
Peterson's lecture
Jordan Peterson now who I liked but I
don't know where he is now he's in a
youth hostel I haven't heard from him in
a little while
I think they've strapped him to
something he'll be back he'll of a
comeback tour no harm no foul smart guy
not going to him point is this
Reuben opens up for him Reuben is a
stand-up comic in the same way that I'm
a triathlete you know in the way that I
used to swim when I was eight and I've
ran occasionally and I know what a bike
is so Reuben in that respect is also a
stand-up comic so Reuben comes out opens
for Jordan Peterson and you know Reuben
has his slimy serpent like way of
talking he's like and and every time you
would hit what was not a punchline but
he thought it was just a pause the crowd
would kind of nervously like sort of
laugh and then really like he's had a
lobotomy like he's had a but the man's
in lobotomize they're not you know I'm
not saying you know I don't care what
anybody believes but but when you see
somebody who's quite obviously mentally
deficient I mean it's like these people
all become just a mouthpiece for an
ideology whatever it happens to be who
cares
okay so chick-fil-a's decided you know
what we used to back a lot of anti-gay
charities we're gonna decide not to
because we're a corporation and we're
trying to sling chicken sandwiches and
then so a guy like Dave Ruel redid a
Rubens tweet right now cuz it's truly
amazing that this came from an adult by
the way not only an adult a guy that
thinks he's funny like this is a guy
that thinks he's funny which is more
offensive to me thinking you're funny
and not being funny is more offensive to
me than being a Nazi or a communist or
because everyone has points that's the
problem you know all these little
Nazi kids that are running around are
bothering Charlie Kirk yes they're Nazis
but they have points al Qaeda has points
identify has points Stalin had point so
the thing is everybody has points now
the the larger point they're all making
is wrong but if Muhammad auda
had points if you were on the plane
going into the North Tower and Muhammad
auda you said to Muhammad ego why are
you doing this and he goes come the back
of the plane let me talk to you and he
goes to be honest the US has gone around
the country overthrowing democratically
elected leaders what they've done is
they've waged campaigns of terrorism in
our countries that have murdered endless
civilians and they've used that to allow
multinational corporations to come in
and just steal our wealth
you'd go [ __ ] all right I don't want to
be incinerated in two minutes but
Muhammad you got a little bit of a point
and you'd eat your peanuts and you'd go
see whatever my point my point is that
everybody's got points okay even the
people that you don't agree with or that
they believe horrific things there are
people that believe horrific things
there are people that think gay people
shouldn't exist and black people should
the end there listen but then they'll
have a point where they'll be like well
you know you know maybe we shouldn't
abort children after they've been born
and you have you have to go okay that
one yes that that one I'm with you just
like antha
all day I'd be like yes you can't take
over intersections in Portland you can't
throw you can't take shits on the stage
before Jordan Peterson speaks even
though that is kind of funny you can't
do this you three speech shouldn't come
with the threat of violence but a fan of
it turned around and you know said
listen here's the [ __ ] reality
there's a lot of people in this country
that are very comfortable with fascism
and would vote it in tomorrow and usher
it in I would go yeah you're probably
right
you're probably right and if you doubt
that just go to a Buffalo Wild Wings and
yeah so yeah the idea that this of
organized anti-fascist campaign is it
completely insane when you
the country people that love a strongman
that the first thing I do is gonna
they're gonna get out and defend the
police did you see that that thing that
I post on my Twitter about a guy with no
arms or legs I got copies like wrestling
a guy with no arms or legs get the guy's
no arms and legs he's in like a youth
like a group home and the cops like
slamming them on the floor I swear to
God
I swear to god it's like and the people
people will defend that cop so that's
why anti-fur kind of exists is because
there's a lot of people in America
they're there first thing to do is just
you know back Authority so let's read
let's read Dave Rubens tweet by the way
dave rubin here the decision makes
absolutely no sense
chick-fil-a was actually cool because
it's it up to the progressive mind virus
which is canceled culture but these
people just use like buzzwords and this
is everybody on all sides by the way
none of them have brains and thought
they're like they didn't do the
progressive as League okay their their
brains have been eaten he goes so Dave
Rubin now he's trying to be funny right
he's a bland basic [ __ ] like if there
was ever a basic [ __ ] it is Dave root
your drug basic [ __ ] that's what you
are you're just basic that Ruben report
show is like so boring he has people on
and he's like hello do you think that
the progressive left is regressive
there's a great cartoon about it which
I'm imitating which is [ __ ] literally
what he does and then he just goes hey
do you agree you're right
I should be you know at ben shapiro that
that famous clipper bench pros okay I
wouldn't go to your wedding and Dave
rube was a kind of surprised by that but
it's like that's who you're shilling for
dummy so listen to this Dave Rubin and
by the way he's quote tweeting Ben
Shapiro so this is I love
this is what they've Reuben dick he's
funny he goes I'm not going back to that
sad dry pathetic Burger King chicken
sandwich no way no how
back to the home-cooked frying pan you
know back to the home-cooked frying pan
I'm gonna make my own chicken sandwich
hey Dave [ __ ] off
we don't need this contribution from you
you're an adult and you're telling us I
mean that you're gonna start cooking at
home
I love the it's like that's the whole
point of the tweets like I'm not going
back to Burger King I'm gonna go cook at
home while my husband goes out and [ __ ]
other men I hope he is I pray to God
Dave Reuben I was [ __ ] other men that
[ __ ] zombie it's a reality folks
boycotts don't work remember everybody's
trying to pull after Trump got elected
they were like try to boycott uber and
then they found out that the president a
list like owned slaves and they're like
well what are we gonna do now I'm
kidding about the president Liv I don't
know why it would but he's involved in
something question you're never more
than three steps away from something
that's not good it's the way it is and
what do you 3:00 a.m. you're standing
outside of a bar what are you gonna do
go back to drunk driving that would be
great would that be great a bunch of
accidents what happened why did you kill
that family I'm not taking uber I won't
do it he's part of like this too covered
in blood do you know that the CEO of
uber is part of Trump's Economic Council
yeah we just took two kids out of that
car they're both dead well it's better
that than them living in a world where
Trump's the president
I Drive drunk that's a great point Cup
boycott Oh Burt drive drunk I just
imagine some dynasound be like
chick-fil-a he's not a Christian company
anymore what I have planning to do is
I'm gonna go buy some salmon some quinoa
I'm going to grill it I'm gonna make
asparagus I'm
make a salad of arugula and lemon juice
and olive oil I'm not even gonna use no
store-bought dressing and then I'm gonna
walk do some light cardio these
chick-fil-a things made me decide that I
maybe I should survive get your fat
Christians threatening chick-fil-a is
the funniest thing I could ever think
just fat people imagine threatening a
corporation that you're not gonna use
their imagine being that person that's
like no more not for me anymore by the
way how embarrassing is it these people
like I chipped fillet every day and no
more it's like why are you letting
people know that you have that much of a
dependence on a fast food company why
are you letting people know that how
sick are you
I see chick-fil-a every week it's like
what why I'm saying that in public the
Twitter's public people can see that
they know that you're eating a chicken
sandwich from chick-fil-a every week
that's part of your routine on earth
that's what you've chosen to spend your
time doing on the planet with the one
life that you have you've chosen to eat
chick-fil-a so much that you're
emotionally invested in what the company
does I'm gonna boycott chick-fil-a
because that's right so I've spent my
life eating chick-fil-a there is
literally tweets from people I've spent
my life eating chick-fil-a no more no
longer I mean
grow up grow up imagine caring would a
coorporate like imagine expecting
morality from a corporate I mean these
are the people that wait to like fire
people after Christmas so that they can
work all the holiday chefs and then go
by the way we're done bye-bye
I'm not saying all corporations are
inherently evil but the idea that you
[ __ ] expect them to mirror your own
morality and it's also guys kind of
outdated it's a little outdated
the idea that you're expecting a
conglomerate to reflect your values when
your values come from the Bible or
the Koran or the Torah hey guys you got
have a better argument there's a lot of
good arguments for things that are in
the black not murdering people
you'll be surprised there's great
secular arguments for not murdering
people there's great secular arguments
for not [ __ ] children coveting your
neighbor's wife
stealing great secular you got a make
but you can't just hold the Bible up and
say this is the way I want my chicken
sandwich shop to behave and if if they
don't behave like this the same way on
the other side if the chicken sandwich
shop wants to believe in the Bible and
and and and and support policies that
originated in the Bible you can think
it's stupid or you cannot eat the
chicken cent it's not a big deal either
what you just don't eat sandwich if you
don't like it you go I don't like I'm
not going to support it that's all folks
how many times have we told you about
the great benefits of the ridge wallet
okay the ridge wallet is a minimal front
pocket wallet that's designed to
streamline what you carry every day it
has 30,000 five-star reviews and it's a
better way to carry your cash and cards
my father lost his wallet in New York
City once he left it on a phone booth a
payphone that's when people used to have
to use pay phones and he put it on the
payphone and he walked away and I think
he took like 20 30 paces steps and then
he turned back and he ran back to the
phone and it was just gone and a sea of
people had come and gone and that those
few seconds and he lost his wallet
you know his wallet was big and bulbous
it was stuffed with business cards of
everyone he had ever met you know
receipts gum wrappers cash but not a lot
of it a lot of ones nothing it was a big
hunk of [ __ ] much like my life my
childhood and the life that he provided
for our family it was just technically a
wallet it was technically a life it was
technically in existence but like
everything else it could have been a
hell of a lot better it could have been
more focused more streamlined you know
he could have worked harder tried harder
took more pride in what he was trying to
do so his family as a project as a brand
looked at me and my mother and tried to
remake us into our best selves so he
could bring us out make a better class
of friends with us get into a higher
echelon of society make more money he
decided not to do any of that he decided
to keep things as they were go along to
get along get along to go along
whatever he's not a bad man this is just
what he chose to do he didn't see his
wife and his kids as a project that
could just be improved and you know
that's unfortunate my mother went insane
and I'm a gay cocaine addict is that his
fault probably probably I don't do
cocaine anymore and I haven't for many
many years but who knows I'm sure
relapse is coming and this time it'll be
crack god only knows what I'll do just
lock myself in the Safari Inn in Burbank
just smoke and rock every night why well
because my father didn't really put as
much effort into things as he could have
starting with his wallet which was an
old worn piece of leather like a big
baseball glove that he took out of his
pocket fumbling around with business
cards desperately trying to seem
relevant in a city that didn't care
about him in a business that he was only
doing fine at you know what I'm saying
is if he'd had a sleek metallic wallet
that only kept a few cards only the most
essential things only the most essential
credit cards maybe you shouldn't have a
wallet with 65 credit cards that you've
maxed out shouldn't be putting it you
know a trip to Disney World on your
Discover card
limit yourself discipline my father
didn't have these things neither do I
see your family as a tool to advance
yourself have a level of pride have some
standards shape these people and mold
them and always lead by example and the
example is to have a sleek streamlined
Ridge wallet okay I'm telling you right
now this is the type of wallet that
you're going to need because quite
frankly you are many of you out there
are really in trouble you don't know
this but you're you're you're in a world
where the Chinese are trying to beat you
you're gonna fight the Chinese one way
or the other
you understand that
they have the population they have a lot
of the money soon they'll have more of
the money they have the dedication the
commitment they're hard people they're
tough they want it they want to win
they aren't soft like us they want to
know what it feels like to be the best
that's very important what do you have
you have the ridge wallet you have the
ridge wallet but it ain't nothing it's
not nothing it's a hell of a lot better
than pulling out a big old piece of [ __ ]
but the ridge wallet isn't only a wallet
it's a way to start streamlining your
life I'm telling you it's a great way to
start eliminating your friends you know
speaking your family only in the most
essential periods of your life trading
up get better friends get a better
family move to a better state get into a
better situation the ridge wallet takes
all the maybes in some days and maybe
this personal call maybe this business
car it'll be my way out maybe this chick
that I [ __ ] will call me back if you
scribbled a number on a whatever because
her phone was dead even though that's a
lie and the numbers fake and you're a
rapist the point is this take all those
some days and maybes and trade them in
for the certainty of the ridge only a
few essential things you need a debit
card a credit card your attorney or your
manager at your bank I don't know you
just you put it in and then you go to
the world and you beat the Chinese for
Christ's for your children so that they
don't grow up to smoke crack cocaine
which I will eventually take some pride
in who you are and the battle that's
coming Ridge comm / Tim T I am ten
percent off your order Ridge comm / Tim
I'll say it again if you need a wallet
you enjoy the show get out there and get
a [ __ ] Ridge Ridge dot-com / t IM
secularism has become a religion so what
you now see is is the return to like
this weird medieval Christianity or this
evangelism that's like end times q and
on Chad where they think Trump is like
appointed by the Lord to fight the bend
x battle it's it's really it's just like
it's a it's it's a species that longs
for its extinction really humanity's a
species that has done more than any
other species to bring about its own
extinction we want it we want it soon
and I think down deep it's because we
know that we're the issue but like this
whole idea is you read some of the Q and
on threads and if they fuse it so
closely with end times Christianity it's
like the rapture trumps gonna ride in on
the white [ __ ] I mean this is this is
her craziness I don't care what you
believe believe all of that but don't
expect the burrito shop to also believe
you know I mean how far do you want to
take this alright I won't eat it
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a doesn't
recognize the supremacy of Q why is it
chick-fil-a talking about Q what why
didn't it flake talk about Q aina if you
are gonna talk about Q a noun I'm
eating your sandwich there's a war
happening and you've been pretty goddamn
silent chick-fil-a like why not make
them go all the way why start with four
why not why not round up gay people and
kill them I mean if you really want
chick-fil-a to fight the biblical
battles you so think should be fought
why why do any of this you're not open
on the shabath on shindy I mean let's
let's really let's go down all those
rules in Leviticus and let's see how
many of them chick-fil-a breaks on a
daily basis I bet they break a few I bet
there's a few that they break but let's
take it all the way I am upset I am no
longer eating at Wendy's because Wendy's
does not hasn't talked about chewing on
so if Wendy's doesn't talk about Q I'm
out because we're in a shadow war and if
they're not gonna get on board with my
own belief system I know that Q and I'm
people listening to show and they like
message me they get upset it's like guys
if you think the shows good just keep
listing the show I don't care what you
think about anything you're not going to
sway me I have friends that believe in
that [ __ ] that are that are that are
probably more well-versed in it than you
I don't find it believable I'm a
rational human being I'm a rational
human being I have not lost that yet
they have not taken it from me I have
not been so uh you know enraged with
Acacio cortes that I believe in fairy
tales and children's books involving
these uh you know leakers from the Trump
administration okay I haven't adopted
that world you yet because my brain has
not been rotted now one day I'm sure it
will be it's the way it is like
organisms just died but this is you know
these is what it is in the same way I
haven't gone along with the secular woke
crowd I think they're full of [ __ ] I
think they are crazy
you know it's just becoming the right
wing is now like trying to be as
like the right ones getting is annoying
now is the left one where you're like I
truly you know I was in Fort Worth no to
Nichelle and I was out in the audience I
just see people that their worst and
they just take all these people it's a
very volatile divisive time in American
history and then they pour alcohol all
over it and then sit people in a room
for an hour and then I I perform for
them and I mentioned things that are
kind of triggering or hot-button topics
either way and then people just you know
if I say the word Trump people cheer
people boo it's like just listen to the
joke dummy it's not about how you feel
it doesn't matter you can love them or
hate them shut up it's it's it's going
out and doing stand-up is very black
pilling because you realize that we were
a country of children and that
authoritarian power structures are never
gonna disappear because down deep were
hardwired to want them we want a leader
we want a pack leader
we all want somebody to tell us what to
do I tweeted something about Kanye West
I like Kanye West I think his foray into
religion is interesting I think the
modern world's left people feeling very
empty very isolated disconnected
disenfranchised so the revival of
religion and spirituality I understand
that and I think Kanye sings very
interesting things but he's standing
next to Joel Olsteen who's worth
millions and millions of dollars in a
megachurch - Joel Olsteen refused to
open to flood victims by the way and I
just tweeted listen guys the reality is
society cannot be a choice between
consumerism and [ __ ] you know
religious or political extremism it
can't it can't be those two you know
those two um
polar opposite or are they relieving
that opposite but those can't be the
choices they can't be the options we
need to find something in the middle and
that people are like well how is this
how is this Christianity gonna be
because I said people are embracing
belief systems have become dangerous
because they feel so empty people like
well how is this gonna be dangerous
how's Christian
gonna be dangerous and I'm like well
Christianity's has done some negative
things it's done some negative things in
fact it's a great way to fleece people
out of money it's a great way to fleece
people out of money and churches and
pastors have been doing that for a very
long time as the kids who've been abused
by priests uh if Christianity has done
any negative things you know ask anybody
who's given their life savings away to a
charlatan Minister that comes on the air
ii am promising them tickets into heaven
if they if they shine checks from their
beckett ask any of them if it's minute
yeah it's been negative dummy like just
you gotta look at [ __ ] and i'm not
and and militant atheism can be also
very negative and and and people beanie
allistic and I've seen religion do
beautiful things for people but you
gotta be rational and when you have
Kanye West standing next to Joel Olsteen
if you don't see that this could be an
issue down the road I don't I don't know
that I can help you if you don't see
that down the road this could get
interesting this could get very
interesting it might be great but there
is also that possibility that it won't
be that great and that other celebrities
who may not believe in anything might
decide to wear the mask of uh
Christianity in order to make money and
attack that market you just have to view
things like a rational person I'm not
hating on Kanye West I like him but he's
clearly had a little bit of a mental
slip I wouldn't call it a break but some
of the things he says you go I don't
know if what's going on here and you
know I appreciate what he's trying to do
and I appreciate but lets you know get
real a little bit he's standing there
next to Joel Olsteen it was worth a
bazillion dollars because he's selling
the best product ever Christ
and Connie standing next to me I I worry
a little bit
I worry a little bit about the fusion
between big Christian money and massive
entertainers I think that could be a
very interesting road that we go down
I'm not saying that it's gonna be you
know you know uh overturning roe v--
wade or putting gay people in camps or
any of that I'm not some hysterics but I
just think that you know religious
always been a great way to fleece people
out of their own money it's been great
and I'm like I wonder if that's where
this could be going hope not but you got
Joel Osteen grinning like Barabbas the
way standing on that stage and I respect
your loyalty my respect somebody goes on
who goes out there hits his flock over
the head and then when there's a flood
he goes get out of my church few pigs I
respect that the same way I respect the
Long Island medium for preying on you
know the sadness of mothers and fathers
who've lost their children and the idea
that she's able to go to sleep every
night doing that taking advantage of
people at their most desperate and and
making money out of it I give her a real
I say hey good on you good for you
Theresa Caputo for literally preying on
and because they deserve it
they deserve it sorry to say it they
deserve it my grandmother used to say
that if you buy a ticket for that you
deserve it if you buy a ticket for that
garlic not to tell you she's talking to
your daughter that meatball to tell you
she's talking your daughter then you
deserve everything you get can't be mad
at her not mad at Joel Olsteen
you want to write them you want to give
them all your money give them all your
money doesn't not a big deal the Tim
Dylan show is sponsored by can i ProGear
the world is going to hell in a
handbasket well this certainly this fits
in with my show now doesn't it some ads
you read and you got I don't really know
but they know me these people you got to
be
ready for battle and it starts with a
good backpack throw out that JanSport
set your NPR tote bag on fire hopefully
none of you have an NPR tote bag yet can
i ProGear I mean this is the reality
folks and I I don't want a black pill
everybody and I don't want to sound you
know apoplectic but it's coming you know
I don't know from what side it's gonna
be I think it might just be utter chaos
I don't think it's gonna be a us versus
them good versus evil I think it's just
gonna be marauding bands of you know
ultra violent separatists people that
have separated themselves from society
that you know are poorly trained in
hand-to-hand combat they're gonna be all
over the place it's gonna be
Charlottesville every day but not even
about race relations it's just gonna be
about people that want water people
gonna be marching for water they're not
gonna care about statues being taken
down they're gonna be like remember when
we used to drink water whenever we
wanted I'm telling you it's getting
there it's really gonna get there
there's nothing we can do about it
political solutions don't work
technology is only gonna exacerbate as
many problems as it's gonna fix
there's too many trends converging right
now that suggest that the future is
gonna be filled with climate fuelled
emergencies massive civil unrest
political corruption pandemics food
shortages natural disasters what are you
gonna need can I give their backpacks
are inspired by military assault pack
what's going on this had this what's
going on here I mean really
they took military-grade materials like
500d Cordura nylon the brand name nylon
don't you know which is the strongest
light it's the most durable this thing
wouldn't have survived an Epstein cell
that's literally in the ad copy
that's literally in the aircon what kind
of they really know they were audience
man this company's like really focused
in on [ __ ] a podcast audience Wow
it's in use by the US government if it's
trusted by Secret Service agents it's
good enough for you well where were they
when Kennedy went down dealing all right
let's not get lost all their backpacks
are designed with functionality in mind
here of this high quality normally cost
an arm and a leg but it can I you can
get the highest grade at a fraction of
the price listen if you need a backpack
I have one right here this is a killer
backpack this is a backpack that's going
to allow you to survive and melee which
it sounds like they're marketing it for
a melee they know who they're talking to
they get it you know this is the type of
backpack you're going to be able to
travel with much-needed supplies you can
restock up on food and water if you need
to while you're on your journey to you
know wherever you happen to be going
maybe Nancy Pelosi's house I don't know
it's not my business I mean I love how
dark this ad is it's dark but it's also
kind of light it's like you know what's
coming nothing good you're gonna need a
backpack made of strong nylon that [ __ ]
wouldn't survive an Epstein cell we're
at the end of the Empire folks and
you're gonna need a tough backpack maybe
some weapons some hand-to-hand combat
training I mean is this for like
Preppers it's kind of like a doomsday
prepper thing but I did that because
Preppers are only gonna be called people
that woke up first
pretty soon it's easy to make fun of
Preppers with their pyramids it can spam
waiting for the end but don't worry I
love those luxury you know it's funny
when you you look at those luxury
doomsday like that's a fun person who
has a luxury doom
stay apartment like deep in the earth
like you know you'll see every now and
then they'll trot them out when it's a
slow news day they'll be like well
there's also people that have you know
that's a million dollars each for a
luxury apartment underground just in
case you know so III always find those
things fascinating they always they
always get the time of day for me if you
have a luxury doomsday apartment I will
always take a look at it just out of
curiosity their Holiday Sale is on now
and with my code temte I am you can add
an additional 15% off and for a limited
time only if you spend over $40 they'll
throw in free shipping tonight ProGear
comm CA and naep ROG e AR dot-com can i
ProGear comm and all of their products
come with a lifetime warranty no matter
what happens rest assured can I will
repair or replace any back as long as
you walk the earth getting a skirmish
with local riot police no biggie can
eyes got you covered
little tear gas screwed your backpack up
they'll help you maybe got ambushed on
the corner you weren't expecting it
semadar kiss gotcha don't worry can i'll
replace that as long as you walk the
earth
get the last backpack you'll ever buy
Jesus
this is really did I write this have I
feel like I wrote this ad get the last
backpack you'll ever buy it can I see a
and n AE ProGear comm used Tim to get
15% off oh my god I do not even want to
read after the bombs there will only be
you and can i pro gear the most durable
back leg known to man are they trolling
us is this a real company I mean this it
almost sounds like we're being trolled I
mean it oh my it literally almost sounds
like we're being true there little Dave
lifted lines I've said on this show and
they've made it into a
backpack head which I respect it is a
durable backpack they're really leaning
into their audience some apps team jokes
they know they knows out there folks
Wow if you need a backpack and you like
the show it's the same thing I say to
everybody if you need a backpack and you
like the show this is a great way to
support the show it's a great company
it's a very durable backpack there's
kids that listen to this show in college
some of them I've met a few high school
kids that came out to the show was
hilarious I was like I have no idea
we're reaching the youth I thought they
were all on tick tock and most of the
bar let's get real but you know people
out there might need backpacks people in
the 20s and 30s 40s might need backpacks
50s who knows it's great way to make
yourself feel young to have a nice
backpack on the way to a riot so can i
procure calm promo code tim by the way
if you're Long Island if you're a Long
Island head which some of the people
listen to show are you got to watch the
show called I forget what it's called
it's called pile unpolished
and it's about this family of people
that do nails in Long Island called the
Martins and it's like it's like a first
of all can we say this so many women in
Long Island that are like very Italian
or almost trance-like and I don't say
that in a negative way and I'm not
trying to insult anyone but I will say
that I am open more to these fluid
gender arguments when I see like Long
Island Italian women XE and I'm like you
know maybe we don't have it all down
here maybe it's not as simple as just
men and women when you see Long Island
Italian women there is a real masculine
energy to these broads it's interesting
and they have this new show about the
salon they have anything
he's Northport where they do like
extreme nails you know one of the one
woman comes in because hi I'm going to a
sing a song right a conference you know
by the people in Long Island should be
legally prohibited from ever entering
the arts sure this woman comes in and
she goes I'm gonna sing a storm right at
conference I need my nails to play music
because I want something to
differentiate me from everyone else at
the conference and at that point I would
have said like hey what about your
talent but she's smart enough to realize
she needs something else so she has this
woman who runs the salon and go find a
way to put one of her songs which is
horrific if you watch the episode put
one of her songs in her fingernail so
that when she they make her fingernail
into a boombox so when she taps the
boombox the songs keep starts playing
can you imagine being at whatever
[ __ ] music convention this was and
you have this Long Island goon walk
around go look at my nyl look at my nail
it's a bull box it plays my song and
then she just starts tapping her boom
box nail and the song starts playing the
song is so bad but it's a the show is
sometimes I miss Long Island and the
shows like a fascinating glimpse into
what Long Island is she's like my
father's like Tony Soprano they even
breathed the same and her father's a big
guy and if I was like and I'm like he's
dead the guy that you're comparing him
to is you know the grandma works with um
you know it's I'm not [ __ ] on them
cuz I respect everybody's hustling on
the island long island strong you do
what you need to do ladies but I'm
saying what's very interesting about all
the gender discussion is when we we have
these discussions about transgender
people we don't include Long Island
Italian women who seem to be on a
spectrum to be honest many of them not
all of them but a lot of them seem to be
on a spectrum it's an interesting
discussion to have clinically let's be
honest
you know dark black hair broad shoulders
big deep voices something's up
[Music]
it's an interesting case study that's my
only point you watched him you're like
this is interesting you know she dates a
guy from a pizzeria and he comes over
the house and she's like what is my
father wants to know what you want for
breakfast he goes oh boy you know Brooke
was because my father won't take dad is
there and you go daughter go burger
juice she goes alright cuz when I was
younger I was heavy and fat and I never
left my room and I learned how to do
nails then I got a gastric sleeve and
now I feel better and now I am and she
is she's impressed if the nail art is
very impressive and then should they run
the salon together salon mark town
they're interesting it's an interesting
show you get a little Long Island you
want a little Long Island UD that's what
you get but it's very interesting to
gender dynamics that you know that are
out there just a lot of these Italian
women a lot of them is very the voice is
a very diverse it's like no one would be
shocked if they had dicks like nobody
would be shocked if you pull down their
pants there's a big hog like a big hog
not even like a small [ __ ] dick that
they made like a big hog and you go yeah
yeah this makes perfect sense cuz
there's just some very interesting and
same way that like Irish certain Irish
women when they get older become they
look like men they look like Irish man
like they have short hair and they just
look like men but that takes a while to
the age the time women like the younger
they are the more like the masculine
energy is peak in their like 20s and 30s
some of them soften as they get older
and then they just look goth it's like a
weird goth energy because they get older
and they're just Darvey things black and
dark but like around their 20s or 30s
they're like Pete look
are you doing my name is Angela I dated
Mike or dated Vito you know Vito and I'm
like what's going on here maybe I'm
wrong maybe all these radical gender
theorists are right and all it took me
was a Long Island Italian woman to
realize that gender might be a construct
this is a dude we just we just said you
should wear a dress but to be honest
with you I don't know
after watching Salon Marton I don't know
I mean these broads are [ __ ] and I
respect them that's the other thing I'm
not hating on them I'm sure they're
women I'm not saying about women but
they have an energy of the dude I don't
give a [ __ ] about energy of a dude and
you go like this is interesting maybe
there is some something to be said for
gender fluidity I don't know that's the
thing that's the other thing about
chick-fil-a we've had the best
sandwiches in Long Island forever the
chick-fil-a sandwich is very good but we
have had we have had such amazing
sandwiches in Long Island for so long
did anyone getting upset about a fast
food sandwich he's kind of crazy because
I grew up with amazing delis places like
my hero and Belle more places that were
just so [ __ ] great and are still
great soft hero roles and you know
really good food nice juicy chicken
cutlets crisp bacon lettuce tomato
mayonnaise little ketchup little trumped
runny 20/20 hat right on the sandwich
but I mean these were great the chicken
club of my heroes legendary we're
talking about meatball parmesan chicken
parmesan fried eggplant fresh mozzarella
[ __ ] red peppers we're talking about
sea
sandwiches bacon America cheese Russian
dressing on a [ __ ] roll
bacon egg and cheese tuna salad with
bacon and cheese on a garlic hero [ __ ]
you so it's hard for me to understand
when people get knots over a fast-food
sandwich go to Long Island go live in
Long Island yes there are negatives but
the positives will be you will get some
serious sandwiches rare roast beef
melted mozzarella cheese some sauteed
onions on a [ __ ] garlic hero change
your life what about a little meatloaf
sandwich with some vodka sauce how about
that [ __ ] how about a little London
broil and some fried onions on there how
about a buffalo chicken cutlet with
crumbled blue Fagor stop stop arguing
about [ __ ] sandwiches it's a good
chick-fil-a is good but it's far it's
mass-produced it's good it's not
life-changing I know what life-changing
food is I hate it Perry's the other
night in Dallas I love a corporate
steakhouse why is a corporate Steakhouse
so good I wanted to be dark
I want people there talking about real
estate scams and [ __ ]
I want prostitutes I want tan couples
that just got back from an unfulfilled
VOC a vacation hovering right above
misery silently eating crab cocktail I
want that I want shellfish towers I want
bosses trying to impress their new hires
I want new hires trying to impress their
bosses I want everybody with their tents
and their dicks out
I want collared [ __ ] shirts I want
maitre d's that grab you by the arm and
say is everything okay I want to canted
[ __ ] buckles red wine I want shrimp
scampi and rib eyes and porterhouses I
want [ __ ] aged rib eyes I want
[ __ ] Wagyu you wagga wagga wagga
whatever the [ __ ] it is it's fake anyway
there's seven restaurants serving it no
you idiot you're paying for it it
doesn't matter
I want [ __ ] slabs of beef and pork
chops and veal chops I want yoki
I want [ __ ] people and shoots sitting
around a table trying to swindle that's
what I love and I wanted to have more
than one location I want to know that
the exact same thing is happening in
Dallas in Chicago in New York at Miami I
want to know that all across the world
demons from hell are dressed to the
nines eating rib eyes I'm deciding if
they're man enough to have a [ __ ]
piece of cheesecake or a Bananas Foster
at the end I want a corporate steakhouse
except Ruth's Chris I hate Ruth's crest
it's a that's a mall steakhouse [ __ ] you
of you eating Ruth's Chris I want to
tell Frisco zora Smith and Wollensky I
want a paries I want to ocean Prime I
want a Capital Grille I want consistency
I want a menu design in a boardroom by
suits I want every location to be the
same I want to know that the sriracha
vinaigrette at the pokeball is the same
everywhere I [ __ ] go and then I don't
have some [ __ ] artist chef gonna ruin
my favorite dish cuz he thinks he's
special you're not follow the [ __ ]
rules the system exists for a reason
Marxist scum but I will say comrade I
will argue an appetizer every now and
then off my tab just say this wasn't
really what I thought it would be but
that's what I want it's my favorite type
of restaurant it's always been the
corporate soulless Steakhouse that's a
reality if people don't spend their life
trying to acquire things they will they
they fall into some type of weird quasi
spiritual genocide 'el mania they need
little dumb things to do they're beasts
of burden as jordan peterson said they
need to make enough money to buy
themselves uh mashed potatoes with
lobster on top of it for no goddamn
reason even dates good doesn't even
taste good but Alan Stillman knew this
you started Fridays and TJ Smith of
olinsky's DT
tell Frisco knew this who started the
Frisco's whoever the [ __ ] Morten was
that fat [ __ ] who started Morton's and I
don't really love Morton's but it'll do
I don't like Mastro's out here in LA
it's it's it's I don't like it my point
is a good corporate steakhouse that's
what you tell your woman you're going
you know you're not going to some
[ __ ] open anyone ain't going you know
this little you know 212 c12 table
restaurant and all their food source
from a shut up we're going to a
corporate steakhouse with my father
that's what we're doing cuz we've been
going there for ten years and he's
almost dead make a [ __ ] memory you're
gonna have your petite filet mignon your
Chardonnay either shut the [ __ ] up cuz
this is a corporate steakhouse and we
deserve this this is the way my father
loves me we go and eat we fill ourselves
with fat salt and sugar and bread and we
feel sick when we leave doesn't matter
we toss in return we do not sleep well
that night because our body should not
be digesting this level of food but it
doesn't matter because as we're tossing
and turning everything we ain't goes
into a [ __ ] column of profit for that
corporate Steakhouse and it indoors and
it lives forever and it gives senators a
place to take prostitutes and it gives
older couples a place to just have that
final meal before they decide they don't
want to see each other again until they
lay down and matching burial plots I
just love a Corp I will never love any
restaurant as much as I love a corporate
steakhouse the transience of the people
they'll all be they're all dying and
there'll be another crop of them moving
in the maitre d that pretends that they
care the lonely people like me sitting
at the bar
most of them boozing me just eating and
then the bartender is saying remembering
our names hey thanks for coming Tim yeah
hey thank you thank you I won't go back
to the hotel and blow my brains out
tonight because
you said thanks for coming Tim cuz they
know it'll be up there now to make you
feel nice cuz it's a corporate
steakhouse
there's not one location there's many
there's accountability there's
structures there's hierarchy things
matter things have to be done the same
way and yes maybe there's not that many
magical moments because you know what
you're gonna get and you expect it so
there's not a lot of magical moments in
those restaurants but guess what the
magics over in this [ __ ] country
you're lucky you're lucky to have
whatever it is that you got there's not
too many magic because nobody's taking
the risks to make the magic because the
risks aren't being rewarded when you
become a brand you can't take risks but
you can deliver a sustainable level of
quality to the people which is all you
should expect you greedy [ __ ] we're an
end stage of an empire and you're
looking for somebody to whip up a
miracle in that kitchen it's not gonna
happen
just get a medium-rare ribeye in a in a
vat of its own fat and a creamed spinach
and keep your mouth shut
stop with the I read a review or this
place looks nice or you know this chef
had an inspiring story she grew up with
one leg and now she makes omelets cut it
out
go to the corporate steak houses sit in
the dark corner and eat what you know
you're gonna like maybe hot love was
like the country is over these temples
of consumerism and slabs of beef are
what is left high-end dining his daddy
died in the 90s after 9/11 people took
the tablecloths off the restaurants
people stopped going to French
restaurants they stopped spending three
hours having tasting menus now all the
restaurants in New York that are you
know three-star Michelin restaurants
they all catered a high-end tourist you
know the Asian tourists things like that
people have a shitload of money and they
hand you like you know some little jelly
cube and it's like tastes like us you
know a carbonated grape fruit and they
go tada and you go no tada
[ __ ] you hand you a bowl that's just a
little sea urchin foam and a and a great
that's taken out of someone's ass [ __ ]
you I will take my corporate Steakhouse
please a nice fat loaf of bread that is
not fresh but it is hot as [ __ ] it's so
hot that I don't remember that it was
here three days ago probably on someone
else's table some other fat slob gnawing
on it I've given up on truly
transcendent dining experiences I've had
many of them but they are over chefs
have become commodities nobody has any
appreciation for art everything sucks
why would food be good that's why you're
all arguing about chick-fil-a shove it
up your ass there's nothing left the
only thing that's left is the corporate
chain steak house with the food that
doesn't even make sense do you want crab
on your steak no but pull sure do you
want a lobster crusted steak I don't
even know what that is but yes why
because I have nothing left in my life
crusted with blue cheese and salmon come
I don't care as long as I pay more than
the market price I want to pay over
Market for this crust it with nine
things I want the tartare to start the
tuna tartare and the beef tartare
throwing a shellfish platter give me a
tomato tomato and onion salad and a
tomato and mood surround what do you got
a the autumn bisque some butternut
squash soup calm that into a bowl and
serve it to me for 18 bucks I have
nothing left
give me a seafood stuffed mushroom if
you want and then you better litter this
table with beef big slabs assault cured
beef fatty bacon I want creamed spinach
and Lyonnaise potatoes au gratin
potatoes mashed potatoes and you better
mash everything into the beurre blanc
sauce butter crab lobster shellfish
stone crab claws you better take a hunk
a rope for cheese and smash it in those
potatoes with your bare hands
because that's what I want I want a meal
that doesn't even make sense I don't
wanted to even make sense I want you to
bring something to the table that I have
to explain to someone while they stare
at me what's on your steak it's crusted
with lobster and a beurre blanc sauce
and a gorgonzola spinach souffle I don't
know
it's a ribeye and it's in a cage of
fried bacon and duck fat and it's just
that's what I want because that's all
that we have left don't look for these
romantic stories of young Chefs
fulfilling their dreams and little
kitchens where they make brilliant stuff
that's all over people yell at those
people can't borrow too much from this
culture you're appropriating their
culture now fusion cuisine was a thing
of the 90s people take French techniques
and Asian flavors can't do that now why
would they do that because France
pioneered classical cooking techniques
and Asian people many of them and
there's nothing wrong with this date at
restaurants where the tablecloths were a
leaf so what you do in those situations
is you bring those things together and
everybody benefits okay so my point of
this rant it's a very food-centric
episode but my point here is do not go
looking for gold do not let the perfect
become the enemy of the good
don't look for a view no good
restaurants I've read of you shut up
what are you an idiot
I know I like a view that's chick [ __ ]
you don't need a view me and Ben went to
a restaurant once in in Malibu the view
was amazing the food was horrific and
then we walked in the bathroom and there
were literally I'm not even kidding I
was like naked children I mean Ben were
like very uncomfortable we're like we
don't understand what is happening why
is this happening
apparently everyone in the restaurant
probably knew why it was happening but
the point is this that's what a view is
you know
we need a view you need to sit in the
corner of a dark corporate steakhouse
the only view you should have is a
couple barrels of wine maybe a brick
wall maybe a wood wall it should look
like a meat locker
dark carpets may be flowing white
tablecloths maybe not I don't know
spiral stairs big lights big leather
placemats knives and forks the name of
the steak house and you know just just
everywhere carved in the tables on menus
everywhere right in your face you don't
want you to ever forget that you're
eating it the first goes even though
you've had multiple strokes because of
their food they still want to make sure
that that [ __ ] that's right out in
front of you right there those are the
steak houses that I grew up in those the
steak houses the restaurants and I'll
always love because for that moment
you're special you go in there and yeah
you're a piece of [ __ ] and you have
nothing and you have no money because
this is what I've been my whole life and
I'm kind of a little above it now but
I'm still that especially in these
places sure you have nothing and you go
in and you barely wonder if your [ __ ]
debit or credit card is gonna work but
for that moment when you bite into that
cold shrimp on ice when you bite into
that cold shrimp on ice nobody in that
restaurant knows you're a dirtbag they
don't know you're a dirtbag you know cuz
you're just sitting there in the dark
people can barely see each other turn
the lights down I woke in the
steakhouses well-lit I go turn it down
turn it down now people want it relaxed
should be they should be like a sauna
with [ __ ] crab cocktail so that's my
point I you know my appreciation for
food started as a young person and IIIi
learned to love the steak houses I
learned to appreciate them I learned to
understand they're meaningless luxury in
many cases I I learn to understand that
that luxury wasn't so meaningless it was
maybe maybe my own naivete now that I
grow older I know that it is nice to
have a little luxury a nice warm bread
roll
a nice little slab of unsalted butter a
creamy butter a nice lobster bisque with
sherry I know that it's nice to not be
in some experiment all the goddamn time
with some chef that you know thinks he's
gonna be the next thing and he's not and
you got to sit there and suffer through
that it's nice to go to a corporate
Steakhouse with your friends family who
are if they're very tan and they don't
love each other and they sit down and
they judge you but you get a nice big
fat free meal for it you know who gives
a [ __ ] and they don't quite love you
they don't quite hate you but you just
kind of stay on their good side with
everything you say there's something
beautiful about those types of meals you
know that's the reality so that that's
what I suggest you go out there and find
that's what I love Dallas Texas because
it was just chain stakeouts after chain
steak house after chain Steakhouse guys
just trying to you know shut up phony
real estate companies built people out
of their money and [ __ ] prostitutes in
hotels while their wife's at home making
stuffing and I connected to that
immediately I connected to it much more
than I'll ever connect to these hipster
pigs that goddamn $800 sneakers they're
whining about you know that nobody gives
a [ __ ] about them and they rightfully
have no fans and no traction in this
business you should you shouldn't those
people on Twitter look at my shitty
career yeah it's for a reason stop
highlighting what's accurate no one came
to my show again correct correct
so here's what I'm saying if maybe
thought I was too liberal in the
beginning of the episode but that I I
redeemed it with a maybe the best
defense of corporate steakhouse ever had
cuz you know one of my friends chick
said one she's like I don't you always
want to go through my record Pratt I
said let me explain something to you you
Pig [ __ ] okay you're a pig [ __ ] okay I
go somewhere corporate because
something that's proven themselves okay
and when you when you [ __ ] out
illiterate kids and your body goes to
[ __ ] and you can't go around dancing
your clubs anymore
you're gonna love a darkroom where you
can sit and and and fill yourself with
bisque she'll keep your mouth shut
and enjoy the pleasures of a simple
sterile soulless vapid corporate serene
environment that's why we come here
because it is serene and there's a
beauty to it shut your mouth you Pig or
Timbaland comedy calm for my live dates
Tim J Dylan di ll went on Instagram and
Twitter please continue to support the
show please continue to eat a corporate
steakhouses they are very good I really
wanted you to open a restaurant but I
would open a corporate Steakhouse it
would be small independent corporate
Steakhouse and I would just say I just
want this to be franchised as small as
my restaurant was would be a corporate
it could be six tables it'll be
corporate steakhouse just get one
chandelier throw out of spiral staircase
going to nowhere of a pretend wine
cellar
I don't care but that's all that we have
left is the country you know so that's
that's kind of the the corporate
Steakhouse is maybe an allegory for
America you know and that's what we got
but that's what it is folks get the
creamed spinach hey everybody this is
Tim Dylan here just addressing a little
controversy the Brendan Schaub episode
which everybody loved I appreciate that
there was actually not one negative
comment to be found anywhere on social
media you know which is very rare most
episodes I do or are you people enjoy
them but there is some mixed reaction
it's only logical that people would have
different feelings but this episode was
one
hundred percent positive comments
well-received appreciate that
YouTube in the infinite wisdom of
YouTube is chosen and remove it we think
YouTube said it was about us selling
something unregulated it could have been
a CBD potentially we don't know has to
do with our advertising doesn't have to
do with our content from what we've been
told we're working with them appealing
that trying to get that back up so that
is what happened we got a message I did
Rogen yesterday we're coming back been
our indefatigable and is it into fat
about what is it in different into
fatigue herbal you're right
yes not okay it's not into the FATA ball
or something I don't think so no our
individual producer he's very fatigued
Abul which is the funny thing about he
sleeps all the sleeps like 13 hours a
day like a junkie um he got an email
from YouTube that what did it say it
said it the video was pulled for harmful
and dangerous content right and if I
looked into that it was because we were
selling regulated Goods without a
prescription or so these are regulated
goods whether it's CBD or whether it's
blue true we don't know i we do still
don't know products everybody sells
products everyone sells we don't know it
seems like it's selective enforcement of
a policy um I don't know I don't know
I'm not listen I've talked enough about
YouTube and what's going on with YouTube
we're all aware of that how that shakes
out I do not know but this doesn't seem
to be a Content related problem it seems
to be something with the advertising but
it does seem to be what seems to be
selective enforcement of a policy I
don't know but that doesn't mean that I
mean that that is a legitimate thing I
mean you know not everybody's gonna get
flag I got flagged for whatever reason
maybe because of all the positive
comments on the episode you know it's
very possible I don't know there's so
many people that were so happy to hear
that conversation happen and it was such
an outpouring of joy
many sectors of the internet that maybe
that just alerted you to but they wanted
to take a closer look at the episode
then they were like oh these guys are
slinging CBD and blue Chu weird not cool
I'm not gonna try to be a hysteric about
the direction the technology is taking
and a lot of these platforms I don't
know I like you I'm waiting to see all
these things unfold I did put on my
story the other day it begins because I
do think something is beginning I don't
know what it is and I you know nobody
knows I mean that the signs are there
that it's gonna be tougher you know
we're gonna have to be a little bit more
careful I also want to address why I'm
not putting a lot of the videos or maybe
all of the videos on Instagram anymore
I'm not willing to lose my Instagram
account for a video especially when
Instagram is not promoting any of the
content we put out so we're not getting
as many views on those videos on
Instagram as we are on Twitter Twitter
seems to be the last bastion of freedom
and I know it's a horrible thing and
everyone's fighting on it and it's a lot
of its political and everybody at listen
whatever I don't own stock in Twitter
but I am Telling You Twitter seems to be
the most lenient I mean there's porn on
Twitter you know and so the reality is
don't tell me like so-and-so got banned
and without like don't I'm not defending
every action a company takes what I'm
saying is for comedy videos they seem to
be I know for a fact they're a hell of a
lot more lenient that Instagram and
probably then maybe YouTube I don't know
so also you know if the videos were
being promoted on Instagram if they're
on the discover page people could find
them but I mean listen you could argue
about shadow bands you could say they're
real they're not real I know that the
video views I've got have plummeted as
every other indicator my career has gone
up I've gained followers on Instagram
I've gained followers on Twitter the
podcast is quadrupled in listenership
over the last year but the Instagram
video views have
so that's either a change in their
algorithm or people can't get to the
videos or whatever and I'm not gonna
complain about it we're not gonna make
every [ __ ] show about it boo-hoo-hoo
no one cares I get it but that's why
they're not on there we'll we'll usually
put a link to the the video on Twitter
and that's that maybe we'll put some
videos on Instagram if they're you know
completely safe but that's not the type
of stuff that we usually do I don't know
we've got a few strikes at Instagram we
have to be careful you know I don't know
what the next strike is gonna be or if
it's gonna be the final strike I'm being
very careful with that account so the
videos are gonna go on Twitter they're
gonna go on YouTube and that's the way
it is and you know they're still gonna
be [ __ ] on Instagram you know and if we
feel like a video is completely safe
well and you know we're not at risk of
being flagged and being reported or
being you know having a video removed
then you know we might put them on
Instagram but as of right now you know
we're being careful with that you know
which I think any anybody right now that
is creative in any way has to be very
careful with anything they do because
you build a career using these platforms
and you don't want to lose access to
your fans how to sell them tickets you
don't want to do any of that over a
stupid little thing so instead of
censoring and making shitty or videos
that are unfunny we're just putting them
on Twitter not a big deal that's okay
Instagram will still be a fun place
they'll keep you know still keep putting
all my dates my live stuff out there
ticket links you know funny funny stuff
you know when we make it but you know
being a little bit more careful with
that you know which i think is
reasonable you know hopefully they put
the Schaub youtube we were about fifty
thousand thirty thousand I think about
thirty thousand views on that and you
Gillett Gillis is up to fifty thousand
says up to 50,000 so you know we're
building a channel 1 the infancy of kind
of building this channel and you know
the podcast has grown tremendously so we
appreciate that we appreciate everybody
on patreon we appreciate everybody who's
just sharing it with their friends and
family you know tweeting it out re
grabbing it putting links places you
know sending people YouTube videos
telling people about me over
Thanksgiving when you go home and you
say hey if you want to divert attention
from a political fight Tom about the
show tell him about us you know we go
hey hey enough with that and John and
Shawn did I say aunt Shawn I think so
yeah well that's a trans aunt who's
getting crazy
that's aunt John and John what she
doesn't want John identifies as a female
but likes her old name it's very
confusing Shan Shan and aunt John just
likes to booze it up and aunt John even
though she's trans is an
ethno-nationalism loves whites so if
aunt John's boozing it up and she's uh
you know talking about the ethnos day
and you're like hey aunt John hey aunt
John how about you listed Tim Dylan show
it's real fun and he's gonna go she's
gonna go what's that I don't even know
folks I don't even know what I just said
we're probably banned we're off apple
podcast we're done they're done we're
done - all over in a few years I'll just
have a website we'll host all the video
on the website you know it's good that
all of these companies are treating us
all like militia leaders you know what I
mean isn't that nice that you all have
to [ __ ] like I shouldn't even be
thinking this way you know I do stuff on
Comedy Central on the David Spade show
the you know it's funny and it's on a
cable news now
[Applause]
yeah but it's just the idea this is kind
of funny it's funny when you think about
the inner workings of these companies
that they work there's so much content
so many people putting out so much stuff
there's not enough people and some of
them are poorly trained when they're
reviewing these complaints to these
problems you know it is what it is I
don't
I don't have too much of an interest in
it to be honest like of all the things
going on in the world right now the
inner workings of these companies I have
to know about because they affect me
greatly but I have not because they
don't interest me outside of that too
much I haven't really spent a ton of
time in my life wondering how decisions
get made at Twitter just having just
trying to be funny
haven't really thought about this stuff
now I'm thinking about it more and more
which is necessary but you know I'd love
to wash my hands of it all and go who
gives a [ __ ] and just be funny because
that's all I'm trying to do and it's you
know that's what you people want for me
is to be [ __ ] funny that's it you
know and I get it you know
so in closing I was gonna make a joke
that I see I'm censoring myself now I
was gonna say in closing Heil Hitler as
a joke we can say there's a joke it
would be that's funny but I can't I
can't even do it like because of my own
[ __ ] they're gonna Qi this podcast
will be a transcript and somebody's
gonna read it back one day without any
of the inflection or without any of the
humor and the clerk did you say Heil
Hitler
after a long complained about I mean it
ain't gonna be like that's what's
terrifying about the transcription of
the [ __ ] podcast they're gonna read
it back there's gonna be some dry you
know person from the ministry of
information reading it back to you and
you're like no what I said it was funny
no what I said it was funny it was a
joke they're gonna be like well you know
well why is this funny it's like well
it's not funny when you say it Brazil
the great Terry Gilliam film Brazil
watch it it's a fun movie and that makes
me think of that you know the Ministry
of Information you know this this wild
bloated government and all this you know
all these rules and regulations that we
all have to follow
well we have an episode out before
Thanksgiving now right this is the
Thanksgiving episode yeah yes oh yeah
this is gonna be our Thanksgiving
episodes hey everybody happy
Thanksgiving happy Thanksgiving I hope
you enjoy it
you know I hope you go back to your you
know it's fight it's important to go and
see the people that ruined your life
it's important to look at them they
poisoned you they fed you Wendy's they
didn't teach you anything about managing
money they didn't push you to get into a
good school they let go to some state
school they didn't provide you with the
emotional or psychological resources so
you became a drug addict sex fiend booze
hound you know but it's important to go
back and sit down with them eat some
turkey you know and see where it's at I
mean that this is these are the people
that you're close to I mean it is what
it is everybody wishes they could go
back and do it all over again but you
can you know so just enjoy it and maybe
maybe you're going back to people that
really did the right thing by you that's
fun too you're lucky no matter what you
are you lucky even if you were adopted
by foster parents and they just beat the
[ __ ] out of you every day and burn you
with lit cigarettes
you're lucky gotta say to yourself
you're lucky no matter what happened
somewhere Johnny Gosch is sitting there
going I'm lucky he is you know we're all
lucky for those real [ __ ] fans of the
show you'll know who a guy named Paul
Bonacci is Paul Bonacci was this guy who
was tortured endlessly sexually molested
by you know I don't know everyone in the
country like you the guy had a horrible
[ __ ] childhood watch you too Johnny
if you haven't seen it and Paul Bonacci
was on Facebook one day just complaining
about cell phone service he was shooting
on t-mobile so it made me think no
matter what happens to any of us in this
and country we're all just gonna end up
on Facebook complaining about our
cellphone carrier there's nowhere else
to go and that's the true sign of a
healthy and vital nation that no matter
what they do to you
it can kidnap you [ __ ] ya tortilla split
all your personalities off and at the
end of the day you go right back to the
book and you start yelling your head off
about t-mobile Happy Thanksgiving and
good luck